[الموسيقى]
ارتبطت الأنظمة الغذائية النباتية
بالعديد من الفوائد الصحية بما في ذلك
تقليل مخاطر الإصابة بأمراض القلب والسمنة
ومرض السكري من النوع 2 ، لذلك عند
تناول الطعام بالخارج ، قد تعتقد أن
الخيارات النباتية أو النباتية مغذية بشكل أكبر
ولكن هذا ليس هو
الحال دائمًا  قد تحصل على المزيد من الألياف أو البروتين
في بعض الوجبات الخالية من اللحوم
بفضل الكميات الدسمة من
خضروات الفاصوليا والحبوب الكاملة ولكن
اعتمادًا على كيفية
احتواء الخيارات النباتية المحضرة على الكثير أو
حتى أكثر من السعرات الحرارية والدهون المشبعة
والصوديوم وهذا صحيح بشكل خاص إذا كان
هناك شيء عميق  - المقلية مغطاة بالتوابل
الكريمية أو مكدسة فوق
الكثير من الكربوهيدرات النشوية على سبيل المثال
قد تكون البطاطا المقلية نباتية ولكن هذا لا يعني
أنها يجب أن تكون جزءًا منتظمًا من نظامك
الغذائي ، فالوجبات الجاهزة هي وجبة
صحية فقط مثل مكوناتها لذا انظر
للخيارات التي تشمل الكثير من الخضار
والحبوب الكاملة والبروتين البسيط والاسترخاء
على الصلصات والكريمات والجبن